you know you want to test somebody as
far as where they land on the spectrum
of plugged in versus unplugged show my
video show them you know something like
a quick short a video a tick tock you
know something like that and see what
they do with it well I explained red
pill and you and the community to my
girl when when we first met and her
reaction was like who would be against
this she said here you guys are creating
a better pool of men for us women and I
said well why you say that she said
because of the guys I've dated have just
just you know there there's as I said
there's guys who can't manage to get
their lives financially there's guys
with anger issues these guys are alcohol
issues she said if you guys are creating
a community to better men make them more
masculine only crazy women will be
against that I think you know we're
mostly populated now we're plugged in
blue blue-haired crazy women
yeah like like the crazy controlling
solid cystic uh Nutters don't want you
self-aware it's like you know when uh
cyberdyne or whatever it was called from
uh you know Terminator becomes
self-aware that's kind of like how a lot
of these overly obsessive controlling
boss girls are with dudes when they get
red pill they're like oh there's
something wrong with you and it's like
okay fine you just disqualified yourself
see you later bye you know sort of thing
all this does is really uncover how dumb
most people the vast majority of people
truly are yeah the inability to
critically think
you know
to have somebody like Andrew Tate banned
on dozens of platforms all at once to
somebody who understands what that means
and the implications of that that sets
off alarms that's that raises red flags
to most dum-dums it's well Andrew Tate
bad because Facebook and Instagram say
Andrew Tate bad and then they go on
living their lives because these are the
Empire of nothing these are their false
Idols these are the people that they
worship uh big business and big Monopoly
and big Tech and because they've had a
smartphone in their hands before they
were able to even talk uh able to even
talk so it's while I do think I think
the pendulum swing is going to be far
far slower I don't think we're going to
see it in our lifetime I do think that
um it has it is trending in the right
direction but I think there are so it's
so deeply ingrained in our psyche for
people to want collectivism and latch on
to the comfortable thing which is
politicians and big Tech and all these
people are looking out for me in my best
interest because they truly care about
me
and anytime I talk about that buddies
call me up and say hey man like we're
kind of worried that you're venturing
into conspiracy territory and I'm like
go [ __ ] yourself like open your eyes uh
but you know so so I think all it really
does is exposing which makes it easier
for people like us to get together and
say we want to band together and we we
build you guys know I harp on this
probably more than most maybe more than
anyone the idea of drawing a perimeter
around your tribe and saying everyone
else can [ __ ] off and that's why you
know just to Circle it back not to throw
a sales pitch out there but that's why I
really wanted to get involved with this
onboarding piece in the community right
so it's not just about hey look like I'm
gonna Fork over the cash and get in like
Part of Me part of this going through me
now is like if I decide you're not a
good fit and Rich has trusted me when
with this sort of responsibility like
we're just gonna refund your cash and
you're not going to be in like you know
the guy doesn't guy doesn't need your
money right we want good guys that are
leveling up
that can provide value to the other
members so
um you know that that's part of it um
and I'm not gonna you know
throw my integrity and the Integrity of
the group out the window just because
you know I have this title now or
whatever it might be so
um I just thank you guys can understand
that
so you're I said yeah you're tight your
hand to the king just like Game of
Thrones yeah but
um no like even value from the community
and and a lot of people think that you
know the communities are all about flash
cars and flexing and stuff there's a
group of us going into the Wilderness in
West Virginia in a couple of weeks
camping I don't know Squad about the
woods only chopping down trees but I'm
going to learn from guys whose expertise
this is and this is not pulling into a
campsite and plugging in and hooking up
this is leaving your car and Hiking five
to ten miles into the Wilderness and you
you know you're not going out for coffee
in the morning and it's again it's
something I have never ever done and I'm
gonna get value from from these guys
yeah
yeah it's it's uh it's a bizarre State
of Affairs man it's like um you know
that's why when everybody's you know
coming at you with like oh we have to
save the world and why don't you say
this and like I get I get emails and DMS
from guys like you need to talk about
Israel and you need to talk about Syria
and you need to talk about Iran and you
need to talk about blah blah [ __ ]
blonde it's like no I need I need to
talk about the things that matter to me
that's it and things that I think that
are important to men I don't need to
talk about your agenda just because you
know people watch my stuff I'm not I'm
not like I've gotten to the point where
I almost don't even want to do
interviews on my um podcast anymore
unless it's somebody that I really know
like and Trust because I've had people
dupe me you know like [ __ ] losers
that just like make up stuff and then
they complain and they want you to take
down the video after you've you know had
them come on after they ask you to put
them on like stupid [ __ ] right like
you've got to be very very careful out
there and it's like
you know vetting people vetting women
vetting men
um you know you get to the point where
you're older you've got money you've got
good friends and it's like I don't need
any new friends I don't need any new
people you know whatever like I'm good
and going back to the guys that are you
know thinking about joining the
community I try but guys is one of the
most self-regulating group you will ever
get into you will not if if we post a
picture up you're not going to get you
go girl you're gonna be dude you're
[ __ ] fat drop 20. you know
our ticker baseball hat off and put on a
fedora maybe or something nicer you know
some [ __ ] like that yeah yeah I'm a high
value man uh no you're not let's talk
about that
yeah it is what it is right hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out